these two USBC cables look the same they
feel the same
they even smell the same but they're not
the same which is really frustrating
when you try to charge a laptop or
connect them to a monitor and fail
and now that apple is switching iPhones
over to USBC understanding those
differences could matter even more now
to figure out exactly what the
differences are I enlisted some help and
tore these chords apart this is the
sound of forty dollars just Vanishing to
thin air
Pepin gillardi is the co-founder of
Tomorrow lab a firm that helps tech
companies understand how to build
products better we bought a few cables
online that touted different
capabilities here's what to look for
first is how many watts the cable can
handle that determines how fast your
device can charge your device charger
and cable need to support the same level
to get the best performance almost every
cable is going to tell you how many
watts it is a higher wattage typically
translates to faster charging as it
allows more power to flow from the
charger to the device 60 to 100 watts is
typical for regular mainstream laptops
it's fine if your cable can push out
more than that you just don't want
anything less because your device can
charge slower it's the weakest link the
most powerful brick with a slower cable
is going to charge at that lower power
cables rate small devices and
smartphones typically have requirements
between 5 and 20 watts but if you were
going to buy just one of these cables
for power which one would you buy so
this is the cable at the bottom of your
drawer you can use this to charge you
know your headphones you could charge
your phone with it but it'll be slow
because it's hooked up to an Old Brick
if you move up to something like this
power line your device is going to
charge at its full speed if you're
looking to transfer data or move media
quickly pay close attention to how many
gigabits per second the cord supports
that will also be in the product
description the higher the number the
more advanced it is for moving and
editing 4K and 8K videos try looking for
20 or 40 gigabits per second if you are
just trying to do basic tasks like
connecting mice keyboards and charging
headphones 5 gigabits per second will do
the job and then if you want to make
sure that you can move data or you want
to hook up a monitor this is going to be
the cable for you this is a thunderbolt
3 cable if you see DisplayPort or
Thunderbolt 3 and 4 on the product
description then the cable should be
fine for most monitors
I'm almost never moving data over cable
for my phone this cable does it so I
would buy this it's half the price and
it's longer too which I need because I'm
I'm scrolling in bed for quality
assurance the brand matters established
Brands may be more likely to produce
high quality products that meet industry
standards and specifications now I know
when I pay Apple prices what I'm getting
mainstream Brands often invest in
research development and testing to
ensure products are reliable and perform
as advertised oh wow
look at the gorgeous construction of
this that is a seamless piece of metal
that forms the tip here it flares out so
they're forming these in a process that
is not accessible to designers like me
you don't always have to pay a high
price for a good cable not every cable
is supposed to do the whole thing right
because every cable would be
what was this 40 bucks and if I'm going
to ship a cable with a piece of
technology and the thing costs 100 bucks
I can't give you a 40 cable so why is
Apple switching its most popular device
over from its proprietary lightning
cable you can credit the EU it passed a
law mandating a common charging standard
for phones and other portable
Electronics the idea was to reduce
E-Waste and lower cost for consumers
Apple initially resisted but eventually
caved governments you don't get to do
what they're going to do and obviously
we'll have to comply we have no choice
as as we do around the world to comply
to local laws Apple also makes money
from its lightning cable products
there's no way of knowing exactly how
much the company's latest earnings
report says it made 8.2 billion on
wearables home and accessories which
includes its cables
ah now don't toss your lightning cords
just yet other Apple devices like this
Magic Mouse still use that cable for now
but I sure am glad we're going from all
these to just this
foreign
[Music]